Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness.
I am imagining that I am across a coffee shop table
from you, and I've got my napkin here that I scribble on
because anybody I've ever mentored knows that's how I work.
And I'm just imagining that you've asked me, "Darryl,
would you get together with me 40 days in a row and teach me
what you know about what the scripture says about holiness, what God has provided
for us, and how he produces it in our lives?" And so, that's what we're
doing. All right. Today, I want to give you a little bit of a different metaphor
about the process of sanctification
and what God does for us in holiness.
Now, I want to use this metaphor right here.
I'm using the back of my board because I only have one board.
But I want to give you this metaphor.
When I was a kid, I used to love the story of Treasure Island. Right?
Do you remember the story where there's a treasure map, and there's a
place you start, and there's the journey, and the landmarks you go around, and
there's the X at the end. That's where the treasure is, right?
We're going to get to that spot if we follow the steps.
And I remember that metaphor, and I want to kind of grab
that because the word salvation in
scripture is
more of this right here. It's more of a map.
It's more of a long-term thing than it is short-term.
Let me see if I can give you an example.
In the scripture, there are lots of different ways the
word of God
uses the word salvation. So sometimes it's talking about something
that was in the past. So for instance, when we
say, "I was saved,"
that's was. Right? That's in the past.
That's usually we're talking about justification or forgiveness, like Ephesians
2:8-9, "By grace you have been saved." Do you hear it?
Have been saved. It's in the past. It's the gift of God.
And when God does that, he's usually dealing with the idea of
guilt, that I have guilt from past sins I've committed,
and that's what we're generally talking about.
And he deals with it in a judicial kind of way.
Like a judge, he says, "I declare you not guilty." And that's
wonderful. It's a tremendous use of the word salvation.
But there are other ways that the word is used.
For instance, in
2 Corinthians
2:15, Paul says, "For we are
the pleasing aroma to God, the pleasing aroma of Christ
among those who are being saved." Do you hear that?
The are being saved, the same thing back in 1 Corinthians
1:18, where it says, "The message of the cross is
foolishness to those who are perishing, but to us who are
being saved." Do you hear that? So it's like, in this case,
salvation is not something that was or that happened to us.
It's something that is, something that's happening to us right
now. We are in the process of being saved.
Well, that's salvation too, right?
So what does that mean? Well, I'll give you these
scriptures here. Sanctification is usually what that's referring
to. It is not so much dealing with the guilt of sins
past, because that's already been dealt with once and for all, right, by the
grace of God and by faith. But it's dealing instead, not
with guilt, but with the power and presence of sin
now. And it's dealing with it in an actual sense.
So it's judicial here. It's actual in the working out of
it in our lives right now. I am being saved.
I am presently being saved by the reigning, ruling power
of Jesus living in my life right now, saving me from
the power and presence of sin. Now,
there's another way when people use salvation, when the Bible uses salvation,
there's another way it's referred to, and that is it says salvation is something
that will be. So in Romans 13, it talks about
our salvation is nearer than when we had first believed. Right?
So wait, I thought we already had salvation.
No, but now it's saying it's nearer, so it's in the future still.
So there's some parts of salvation that aren't here yet.
Romans 5:10 says, "We shall be saved by the life of
Christ, just like we were saved by his death." Isn't that interesting?
So we were saved by his death, and we shall be saved by his
life. What's it talking about? Well it's talking about glorification.
It's talking about the physical saving from the
physical results of sin. So in the
final version of God's kingdom, where the new
heavens and the new earth are here, and our bodies are redeemed, and creation is
set free from its bondage to decay, we'll be saved.
We'll be saved in a deeper, higher, greater way
than we were even at the moment of our salvation.
He deals with salvation and sin in a final
way. So he deals with it in a way that
deals with all of the results. Every result of sin,
gone, just like that. That sounds pretty good to me.
But when people are talking about salvation, when they use the word
salvation, a lot of times, most times, they're talking about this right
here. They say salvation is this right here, and they think about it this
way. And if they're a
little more theologically aware and their theology is really biblical, they'll also
be talking about this right here,
where it's salvation, the final salvation.
But a lot of times, what I observe is that this right here,
this aspect of salvation, is minimized.
It's almost like this is the good news, and this is the irrelevant
news, and this is the good news that someday is going to happen.
And that's not right. It isn't correct.
The truth is, let me go back to our original metaphor
That salvation, in order to start here and begin this
journey, and in order to arrive here, you've got to have this middle part of
the journey.
That's just as important as the rest.
You don't get here without this middle part of the journey.
You have to take the steps in the middle. You can't leave that part out.
That's kind of important.
In the same kind of way,
all of this is gospel,
every bit of it. The gospel that Jesus forgives and gives us
freedom from the guilt of the past in a judicial moment by
justification, absolutely, yes.
But also the truth that God gives us freedom from the
power and presence and rulership of sin now,
actually, in this present moment.
So you and I have been saved. Oh, yes. Wonderful.
We shall be saved. Thank God, that's true.
But what about
being saved right now?
What that looks like is Jesus ruling and
reigning and saving from the works of Satan and
sin right now. Remember Jesus said, "I have
come that I might destroy the works
of the devil."
Well, now, he did that by forgiving all the sins that we had committed,
and someday he will do that by redeeming all things and bringing them together
in one new creation. But what about right
now? Is he actively ruling and reigning in your heart
and destroying the work of the devil now in you?
So that when you are tempted, is Christ destroying the work of the devil?
When your
spirit is bound to corruption, is he
ruling and reigning now? And is he conquering that
work of the devil? Because that's one, too, isn't it?
Oh, yes. See, salvation has been. Oh, yes. It will be.
Yes.
But we need to deepen our understanding that this is part of the good
news, that Christ saves by ruling and reigning in
us now. This is what a songwriter years and years ago
meant when he wrote, "Holiness unto the Lord is our
watchword and our song." And then he says, "Not our own
righteousness, but Christ within, ruling,"
present tense, "and reigning," present tense, "and saving,"
present tense, "from sin."
I am not only saved from the past guilt, I'm saved to
holiness right now, actively in this
moment. Salvation was. Salvation will be.
Salvation is. See you tomorrow.